D
SAFETY OF ARIZONA COMMUNITIES
AND MIGRANTS.
WELL, LET'S BRING IN REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSWOMAN BETH VAN DIANE
OF -- BETH VAN DUYNE OF TEXAS.
SHE SITS ON THE TRANSPORTATION
AND INFRASTRUCTURE COMMITTEE AND
IS ALSO THE FORMER MAYOR OF
IRVING, TEXAS.
THANKS FOR JOINING US ON "SUNDAY
MORNING FUTURES."
I CANNOT MAKE HEADS OR TAILS OF
WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION'S
DOING.
THEY SEEM TO PUT MIGRANTS AHEAD
OF U.S. CITIZENS AND MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THEM AND LESS
RESTRICTIVE FOR THEM, BUT THAT
MAKES NO SENSE IN THE FACE OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING.
AND FOR PEOPLE TO GO ON
AIRPLANES, THE CLEANEST
SUPPOSEDLY AREA ON -- AIR ON THE
PLANET, AND YOU STILL HAVE TO
WEAR A MASK.
>> WELL, YOU JUST SAID IT,
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS MAKES NO SENSE.
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE SENSE
OF IT, LET ME MOW IF THAT WORKS
FOR YOU.
WE'RE DOING THE EXACT OPPOSITE
OF WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT CONTROL.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A PROTECTING
PEOPLE, THIS IS NOT ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT AMERICANS ARE SAFE,
THIS IS ALL ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU
CAN CONTROL LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS.
AND YET OPEN OUR BORDER.
AND I'M ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE P
I'M VERY PRAGMATIC.
DON'T COME TO ME WITH A PROBLEM
UNLESS WE CAN FIGURE OUT
SOLUTIONS.
THE SOLUTIONS ARE FAIRLY
OBVIOUS.
WHEN THIS ADMINISTRATION CAME
INTO OFFICE, THEY HAD THE
SOLUTION.
THEY HAD THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY, THE
FIRST THING YOU WANT TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THE COUNTRY THAT
BORDERS OUR SOUTH, THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE COMING OVER ILLEGALLY,
FENTANYL AND WEAPONS ARE COMING
OVER AT OUR SOUTHERN BARD --
BORDER, THE FIRST THING TO DO IS
WORK WITH MEXICO.
IT'S THE REASON WHY SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO SPENT SO MUCH
TIME NEGOTIATING WITH MEXICO.
NOT ONLY DID WE TELL THEM IT WAS
NECESSARY, BUT WE LEFT THEM
LITTLE CHOICE.
WE SAW THIS ADMINISTRATION
EXPLODE THAT UP IN ITS FIRST FEW
MONTHS IN OFFICE.
WE'VE SEEN WHAT THEY'VE DONE
WITH IMMIGRATIONS AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT.
UP UNTIL THIS ADMINISTRATION,
THEY WERE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
DEPORT CRIMINAL ILLEGAL ALIENS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION ATTACKED
THAT.
AND NOW WE'RE SEEING ONE OF THE
FEWEST REMNANTS LEFT OVER OF
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL THE
BORDER, THEY ARE EXPLODING THAT
AS WELL, GETTING RID OF IT.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THEY'RE
EXPLODING TITLE 42 WHICH ALLOWS
US TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL WHO IS
COMING IN AT THE BORDER, THEY'RE
CONTROLLING MORE AMERICANS.
AMERICANS WHO HAVE HAD AN
ABILITY, IF THEY'VE WANTED TO,
TO GET THE VACCINE.
AND YET PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
OVER THE BORDER WHO WE KNOW
HAVEN'T HAD THE VACCINE, WE'RE
LETTING THEM MANY AND NOT EVEN
CHECKING.
IT IS HYPOCRISY AT ITS WORST,
INCOMPETENCE AT ITS BEST.
JASON: WELL, THE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER ARE ABSOLUTELY
STUNNING.
I MEAN, RECORD AFTER RECORD
CONTINUES TO GET SMASHED.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS AS
WE LOOK AT THE CHI AND --
ECONOMY AND INFLATION, THERE ARE
LITERALLY GOING TO BE MILLIONS,
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OF THAT HAVE
COME TO THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY,
WHERE ARE THEY LIVING?
WHERE, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A HOUSH
OUR HOUSING.
WE HAVE INFLATION AND FOOD, BUT
WE SUDDENLY HAVE MILLIONS MORE
CONSUMING THOSE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS AS WELL.
>> WELL, IT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO LIVE?
I MOW THAT, YOU KNOW, AS TEAR
COMING IN OVER THE BORDER, WE'VE
GOT OUR OWN GOVERNMENT WHO'S
PUTTING THEM ON BUSES AND PLANES
AND SHE COULDING -- SENDING THEM
TO A CITY NEAR YOU, WHICH MAKES
EVERY CITY, EVERY STATE A BORDER
STATE, A BORDER CITY.
IN TEXAS WE WE ARE SEEING A HUGE
INFLUX OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
AND A HUGE INFLUX OF ILLEGAL
DRUGS AND WEAPONS.
AND QUITE HONESTLY, THE CITIZENS
OF THE STATE OF TEXAS ARE SICK
OF IT WHICH IS WHY THINK YOU SEE
SOME OF THE DESPERATE MEASURES
OUR GOVERNOR IS TAKING TO PUT
THEM ON BUSES AND SEND THEM TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT FINDS ITSELF
TOO BUSY TO ACTUALLY COME DOWN
TO THE BORDER.
WELL, MAYBE THEY NEED TO SEE
WHAT IT'S LIKE IN D.C. WHAT IT
HAS BEEN IN AREA ALL AROUND
TEXAS.
JASON: YEAH, LET'S LISTEN TO
GOVERNOR ABBOTT HERE AS HE TALKS
ABOUT WHAT HE'S DOING.
IT'S PUTTING A SMALL, SMALL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON BUSES AND
DROPPING THEM OFF IN WASHINGTON
D.C.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
A LOT OF LEADERS IN CONGRESS
HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT THE CHAOS
THEY HAVE CAUSED BY THEIR OPEN
BORDER POLICIES.
AND THEY REFUSE TO COME DOWN AND
SEE FIRSTHAND AND TALK TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY MOST
ADVERSELY AFFECTED.
AND IF THEY'RE NOT GOING TO COME
TO THE BORDER, I'M GOING TO TAKE
BORDER TO THEM IN WASHINGTON,
D.C..
>> THESE ARE ALL MIGRANTS WHO
HAVE BEEN PROCESSED BY CBP AND
ARE FREE TO TRAVEL, SO IT'S NICE
THE STATE OF TEXAS IS HELPING
THEM GET TO THEIR FINAL
DESTINATION AS THEY AWAIT THE
OUTCOME OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
PROCEEDINGS.
THEY'RE ALL IN IMMIGRATION
GIST GIST --
JASON: THAT IS JUST ABSOLUTELY
AMAZING.
THEY ARE JUST FREE TO ROAM THE
COUNTRY WHEREVER THEY WANT TO
GO, THAT'S THE WHITE HOUSE
POSITION ON THIS.
>> IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT THEY DO AND THE RESPONSE IN
THE CAPITAL, BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE A LOT OF FOLKS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE LIKE TO TAKE
THEIR LITTLE HOMES IN THEIR
OFFICES WHERE THEY'RE PROTECTED.
I GUARANTEE YOU, YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE THOSE WALLS GO BACK UP
AROUND OUR CAPITOL TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THE POLITICIANS.
BUT WHY WE'RE LEAVING A WALL
DOWN ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER AND
IGNORING THE EFFECTS THAT IT'S
HAVING ON THE REST OF OUR
COUNTRY, IT IS CRIMINAL.
IT NEEDS TO STOP.
WE KNOW THE TOOLS THAT WERE IN
PLACE BEFORE THIS ADMINISTRATION
CAME IN THAT WERE WORKING.
IT'S FAR TOO LATE TO BE ABLE TO
PUT THOSE BACK INTO PLACE, BUT
WE NEED TO DO THAT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU MENTIONED HOW MANY PEOPLE
COMING OVER THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
WE COULD HAVE POPULATED AT LEAST
THREE OF OUR STATES WITH THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME
OVER IN THE LAST YEAR, IN 20
MONTHS.
THINK ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE THAT
IS THAT ARE HERE ILLEGALLY THAT
WE HAVE NO WAY OF BEING ABLE TO
MONITOR, AND WE DON'T KNOW WHO
THEY ARE.
ALMOST 900 PEOPLE FROM
QUESTIONABLE COUNTRIES THAT WANT
TO DO US HARM, PLACES LIKE YEMEN
AND SYRIA, WE ALREADY BELIEVE
HAVE COME OVER THIS YEAR ALONE.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
JASON: YEAH.
IT IS STUNNING, IT IS SCARY AND,
LOOK, THESE ARE HUMAN BEINGS.
WE NEED TO TREAT THEM WITH
COMPASSION, BUT LET'S ALSO
UNDERSTAND THIS IS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, THIS IS DRUG
TRAFFICKING, THIS IS GUN
RUNNING, AND THESE ARE JUST THE
ENCOUNTERS, THE NUMBERS THAT WE
LOOKED AT.
THESE ARE JUST THE PEOPLE THAT
WE ACTUALLY CAUGHT UP WITH.
THERE ARE HOW MANY ORE -- OTHER
OTHERS JUST FLOW THROUGH THE
OPEN BORDERS UNIMPEDED.
AND YOU HAVE BORDER PATROL THAT
WANTS TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT,
BUT IT HAS HANDCUFFS ON
THEMSELVES, THEY'RE UNABLE TO DO
IT.
TALK ABOUT THE HUMAN TOLL THIS
IS TAKING.
>> WELL, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING OVER, OVER A THIRD OF THE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WHO ARE
COMING OVER WHO HAD BEEN RAPED,
WHO HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED, WHO ARE FACING HAVING
TO WORK IN THIS COUNTRY, BE ABLE
TO PAY OFF THE DEBT OF THE FOLKS
WHO HAVE BROUGHT THEM HERE
ILLEGALLY.
YOU THINK OF HOW MANY PEOPLE,
HOW MANY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DIED JUST ON THE PATH HERE
THROUGH THE COUNTRY OF MEXICO.
AND ONCE THEY GET HERE, LIFE IS
NOT EASY.
I'VE BEEN DOWN AT THE BORDER,
I'VE SEEN WHAT THE CONDITIONS
ARE THAT THEY'RE IN RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THIS HUGE INFLUX.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, I MEAN,
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED.
AND YOU'VE GOT, AGAIN, MEMBERS
ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE WHO ARE
MAKING THEM OUT AS DEMONS AND
MAKING THEM OUT AS THE BAD GUY
AND CONTINUE TO CUT THE TOOLS
OUT FROM URN THEM TO BE ABLE TO
DO THEIR JOBS EFFECTIVELY.
IT'S NEGATIVELY AFFECTING THE
COUNTRY, IT IS EMPOWERING AND
INARE RICHING DRUG SMUGGLERS,
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS, SEX
TRAFFICKERS AND AND ALL -- THIS
WAS PLANNED.
THEY KNEW THAT THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THEY WERE WARNED THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN, AND THEY DID IT
ANYWAY.
JASON: THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
THAT ARE COMING ACROSS THAT WE
DO NOT TRACK, THAT ARE NOT
MATCHED UP AND VERIFIED WITH
SOMEBODY, I THINK, IS GOING TO
BE ONE OF THE GREAT LONG-TERM
HORROR STORIES THAT COME ACROSS.
AND A LOT OF THE PEOPLE, THE
MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMING ACROSS ARE NOT FAMILIES.
THEIR SINGLE -- THEY'RE SINGLE,
YOUNG MALES.
AND WHERE THIS COUNTRY THINKS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HOUSED, FED,
GIVEN JOBS AND EVERYTHING ELSE,
I MEAN, THEY CAN'T EVEN HANDLE
IT WITH CUSTOMS AND BORDER
CONTROL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES?
WHERE DO THESE PEOPLE GO, LIVE
AND WORK IN.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO SEE HOMELESS,
THE HOMELESS POPULATION
INCREASE.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE MORE PEOPLE
THAT ARE HAVING TO TAKE
GOVERNMENT ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS.
AND THEN YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
STATES LIKE NEW MEXICO THAT ARE
TAKING PROGRAMS LIKE OUR COVID
RELIEF, CARES ACT DOLLARS, AND
PUTTING THEM INTO FREE PROGRAMS
FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS WHILE
IGNORING FOLKS LIKE VETERANS WHO
HAVE REALLY WORKED FOR IT.
THE COUNTRY CANNOT AFFORD IT.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE LAST 15
MONTHS UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS OUTRAGEOUS SPENDING AND
REALLY NO CLUE HOW WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO PAY BACK THOSE
DOLLARS.
BUT IT'S ENRICHING DRUG
SMUGGLERS, CARTELS AND GANG
MEMBERS X IT'S AT THE EXPENSE OF
OF THE WORKING AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JASON: YEAH.
I THINK YOU MAKE A VERY, VERY
GOOD POINT THAT WE'RE TREATING
PEOPLE WHO COME HERE ILLEGALLY
BETTER THAN PEOPLE THAT ARE
TRYING TO COME HERE LEGALLY AND
LAWFULLY, AND PROBABLY MORE
IMPORTANTLY, BETTER THAN WE DO
OUR VETERANS WHO ARE HOMELESS,
THEY'RE DIAGNOSE ON OUR STREETS,
THEY HAVE SERIOUS DRUG PROBLEMS,
AND WE DON'T GIVE THEM THE CARE
AND ATTENTION THAT WE GIVE
SOMEBODY WHO COMES HERE
ILLEGALLY, AND THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE AND, I
THINK, WILL HAVE SEVERE
REPERCUSSIONS COME NOVEMBER IN
THE ELECTIONS.
CONGRESSWOMAN BETH VAN DUYNE OF
TEXAS, ONE OF THE RISING STARS
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US ON
"SUNDAY MORNI